pour la troisième fois depuis les
événements tragiques de la veille du
jour de l'an des centaines de femmes
allemandes se sont réunis aux abords de
la gare de cologne pour dénoncer les
viols et le harcèlement sexuel dont des
centaines de femmes ont été victimes
elles étaient entre 6 et 700 selon les
évaluations de la police locale la
manifestation était totalement
apolitique organisé par des femmes qui
n'appartiennent à aucune organisation
formelle ce rassemblement avait ceci de
particulier
le mot d'ordre était une dénonciation à
la fois contre le sexisme et les
violences contre les femmes mais aussi
contre le racisme sur leurs affiches et
dans leurs slogans
les manifestantes ont répété qu'elle
refusait d'être associée au groupe
xénophobe de droite qui utilisent les
événements de cologne pour exiger
l'expulsion des migrants et les
participants reconnaissent par ailleurs
que l'arrivée d'un million de demandeurs
d'asile représente un grand défi pour
l'allemagne